this is the tallest and newest onshore
wind turbine in England and all the
money from it's going to one of the
poorest communities
[Music]
welcome to the show and this week we're
looking at whether there's a new dawn a
fair wind if you like behind Community
energy and could this place have the
blueprint for it also on the show
temperatures soar across Europe again
after extreme heat led to 60 000 deaths
last summer we'll look at the silent
Hazard of underground climate change
lurking under the world's major cities
and one million down 7 million to go Kew
Gardens hits a major landmark in its bid
to digitize all the specimens it's
amassed since Darwin's day this
neighborhood just on the outskirts of
Bristol has around 3 000 households many
of them on low incomes so much so normal
but it's the birthplace of something
pretty extraordinary
the people behind these walls are
getting Pennies from Heaven they're like
you got it in big letters what you're
about yeah ambition is believing in
yourself even when no one else in the
world does and that's very good it took
an off-the-wall idea to make it happen I
sat in a pub with another Resident
um after one or too many beers perhaps
um and he came up with the ideal we need
to deliver a winter moment
I said listen you've had far too much to
drink get we're going home
um and the rest I guess is history
the community here in Lawrence Western
scratched together the money to build a
massive turbine they battled to get
startup Finance from local and central
government and then sourced the bulk of
the five million pounds they needed from
open market loans now the right weather
yields a return for both the investors
and the community so how do you feel
when the wind blows like it is now I've
never felt so in love with windy weather
as I do today because because
um that's turning uh the largest wind
turbine England that we happen to own as
a community group and buy those blades
turn in means that we're generating
economic sustainability for our
impoverished community
and here it is the most powerful onshore
wind turbine in England capable of
delivering electricity for 3 000 homes
taller than Big Ben and someone
ironically right next door to a
gas-fired power station
there were just two onshore wind
turbines built in England last year
although the government does seem to be
softening its attitude towards them the
key to getting them built is getting the
community involved not thrusting these
turbines on them there's a phrase in
Denmark where they say during Pig poo
doesn't smell and I think that's the
tree with with this turbine when you
look at a turbine and you own it as
opposed to looking at a turbine when you
don't own it you don't see a blot on the
line landscape you see something that
you really want and without wishing to
mix my farm animals it's in a cash cow
isn't it absolutely and this is going to
go on for generations and we're going to
build an energy Learning Zone just here
so future Generations can learn the
skills for Net Zero David is hoping to
prove that this model can work and roll
it out on a much bigger scale we're
going to develop 10 more and then we're
going to look at how we can look at
across the country people want onshore
wind so we haven't got a problem with
that it's just getting that development
finance and we can roll the next
generation of community turbines we will
be developing the blue print for onshore
wind and it to be community-led this is
about Community energy and energy
sovereignty about owning the asset and
the benefits coming back to the
communities but it's not just about wind
there are different ways of owning part
of your own renewable energy Cash Cow
this Cooperative solar farm is based in
the fields next to Lawrence Western I
was one of a number of people who were
just sort of volunteers who decided we
wanted to get Hands-On in terms of
renewable energy degeneration rather
than leave it to other people we said
okay we'll do it and so we we started
off by raising money to do some rooftop
solar on community buildings and now we
have about 10 megawatts worth of solar
and that's that's enough to power over 3
000 homes individuals can buy shares of
these solar farms and then get a portion
of the money they make there are over
300 schemes like this running across the
country for this solar Cooperative the
rest of the profits go to community
projects in Bristol it gets me up in the
morning it can be so easy to get so down
on on the climate crisis when actually
there's loads of things we could be
doing
and this is one way we can do we can do
it so I'm intrigued about those Orchards
for the Lawrence Western neighborhood
energy projects are not just from the
community they are for the community
Mark sold the idea on practical local
actions not Global aspirations just
beyond those trees there will be the
brand new community Hub within that
Community Hub we're open to deliver a
renewable energy skills academy and
modern methods for construction Academy
in the hope that when and if a Just
Energy transition happens our residents
are best place to take advantage of that
and they're not further Left Behind when
we went out to consult the community on
climate we were met with slandos they
weren't interested they've got more
pressing issues today
they know the ice caps are melting
thousands of miles away but they also
know the ice in their freezers are
mounting nag today so we we took that as
a node we realized that what we were
trying to deliver Community Development
is exactly climate action except we were
coming from it at a different angle the
climate activists don't see gas being
burned they don't want to see uh carbon
being created we don't want to see our
money being burned we don't want to see
that being created
here fighting climate change and
fighting poverty are the same battle
now after the hottest June on record
temperatures in July have taken a bit of
a dip even going below the seasonal Norm
but in Europe we've just learned that
last year's excess heat caused 60 000
deaths and temperatures are on the rise
once again
the dark red on this map shows the
extreme heat across the south of the
continent with temperatures of up to 42
degrees forecast by Monday that's seven
degrees above normal for this time of
year
average temperatures in Europe driven by
climate change have risen more than two
degrees compared to the second half of
the 19th century that's twice the global
rate our energy and climate change
correspondent Hannah Thomas Peter is in
Athens where tourists and residents
alike are really feeling the Heat
it's absolutely baking on the streets of
Athens pushing up towards 40 degrees and
many more days of this left as this
higher pressure area gets trapped over
southern Europe and Northern Africa and
this city is used to the heat but this
is particularly severe heat event and so
they're putting in place lots of
measures to make sure the population
stays safe particularly older people and
the very young let's show you inside one
of the cooling centers that they've
opened in order to keep the most
vulnerable populations safe I'll just
shut the door here to keep all the cold
air in
we're joined by the deputy mayor
of Athens response responsible for these
cooling centers
um
tell me
how important are these cooling centers
and what service do they provide it
seems that they're extremely important
it's something that we really didn't
know about as you can understand because
uh it's been quite a recent phenomenon
uh the heat waves these these kind of
heat waves are quite a recent phenomenon
for Greece I mean we used to have a very
small ones once in every I don't know
two years or so or something and we all
understand that this is has become an
issue a global warming etc etc we all
talk about that but we've never felt it
on us on our skin so it's been so
important to have these spaces for
people for vulnerable people and when I
say vulnerable people I'm talking about
the elderly I'm talking about the
homeless I'm talking about families or
people that are living alone or they
don't have cooling devices there at
their faces of their spaces so we've
seen that little by little it's getting
even more important to have this kind of
spaces and you have people there that
actually can give an advice or only and
maybe only to feel that there's someone
there for you if something happens to
you or if you feel uh whatever difficult
and yeah
is it a good a good sign that actually
it's not that busy here right now people
are potentially at home being sensible
or are you worried that people aren't
using it uh it's either a good sign
because uh of what you're saying or is
it disturbing sign because people don't
know about it even though even if we
started to communicating my thing a week
ago
but we can understand that since we are
not used to dealing with the heat as an
emergency
it you can see if you walk around Athens
you see all people outside and they're
going to their uh work and things that
they're doing even even I saw people
having coffee outside and ahead so the
the warning for me the the very
difficult thing is that people don't
really understand how how important it
is to deal with these kind of situations
thank you so much for speaking to us
here on Sky News this is just one
measure that the government's putting in
place another is asking people not to be
outside through the heat of the day very
concerned that outdoor workers protect
themselves
um there's obviously also been some
extra firefighters deployed watching the
conditions around wildfires very
carefully indeed but an interesting
thought there about how even in Greece
they are not yet fully prepared for
dealing with heat as an ongoing
emergency through these Peak summer
months
well hammer out there has got
extraordinary weather it looks like it's
only going to get hotter back here we've
got the deck chairs but we don't have
the weather to go with it as we can see
I'm with a science correspondent Thomas
Moore because we're going to talk about
some extraordinary weather uh in uh in
India and North America yeah much higher
rainfall there let's start in Northern
India where you can see phenomenal rain
Delhi had
153 millimeters of rain in 24 hours
that's the highest daily amount for July
in 40 years it's slipping away houses
it's Bridges and sadly there have been
several deaths too you can see that for
Osteo phenomenal all of course in
mountainous areas everything gets
channeled down valleys so you're going
to get very fast flowing water and of
course in places like India people using
every bit of available land tend to
build their their houses on the river
banks but even in Vermont in in
well-built urban areas you've got Rivers
which are a burst their Bankers Banks
and and are also flooding huge areas and
President Biden's declared a national
state of emergency see and with both
these things of people linking it to to
climate change absolutely that clearly
rainfall happens but in uh with warmer
atmospheres holds more moisture and that
moisture has got to come down now this
picture of a lake isn't actually to do
with rainfall as it is to do with this
really interesting thing about whether
we are now in a geological era called
the anthropocene in effect that we are
changing the planet so much that it'll
sort of be noticeable in Millennial
history what happened on that this week
yeah so this is Crawford Lake which is
near Toronto in in Canada and it's
special because it's relatively small
surface area but extremely deep that
means that the sediment that comes down
over Millennia doesn't get Disturbed
doesn't get stirred up so when you're
sort of taking a core down through all
that mud you get a a timeline of
everything that's that's fallen into it
now what scientists have been trying to
do is identify in that where is the
point that human activity because comes
visible not just in Crawford Lake but
globally and that that that would become
an indelible marker for human activity
and they've identified it as in the
1950s right now I'm intrigued by that
because we hear a lot about the
anthropocene and how we're affecting the
planet so much today with extinctions
and climate change if you're talking
about the 1950s what is it about it
seems rather late doesn't it because of
course farming then in the industrial
revolution those clearly are impacts of
humans on the planet but it actually
becomes easier to see with Fallout from
nuclear bomb testing so they are looking
at plutonium a radioactive marker that's
quite easy to detect even after several
decades and probably centuries or
Millennia to come and that's like a red
flag this is human activity because it
is a man-made element but the time scale
here is is really daunting isn't it
because like there's a bit of argument
about actually whether we'll be able to
see these things in almost millions of
years which is the definition of a
geological era look this is hugely
controversial because clearly we want to
see whether we are having this effect on
the planet that we're going to leave
behind us even after our civilization is
long gone yes it's it's it's plutonium
it's microplastics it's ash from
coal-fired Power stations all these
things are being laid down in the rock
strata that might persist but will it
last the test of time and we don't know
because plutonium does wither away it
decays something much more short-term
much more simple um I gather they've
been releasing more beavers yeah this is
in Northumberland and on a National
Trust State up there uh they've released
four more beavers and of course they are
brilliant landscape Engineers so this is
part of climate resilience and not only
will they uh create uh dams in waterways
that provide Lush Wetlands draws in lots
more Wildlife but also it slows down the
flow of water so in times of drought
there's more water left in times of
flood it slows down the amount of rain
going down the river so it really helps
when talking about the climate of the
future
Thomas well thank you very much no time
to tell you that I'm one of the few
people in the country who's been bitten
by a beaver you can look that up on
YouTube if you want if we stay out here
much longer we're going to be in our own
uh Beaver Dam
um time for a break now when we come
back we'll be looking at how heat is
being generated underground the climate
of the ground beneath our buildings is
actually changing see you then
[Music]
welcome back to the show and you find me
in the bowels of the building because we
are looking at the fact that it often
gets hot underground driven by all our
man-made structures beneath the earth
now a new report is out saying this
could threaten the buildings above and
I've been speaking to the reports author
that's Alessandro rotoloria from
Northwest Illinois University my study
reveals that the ground underneath the
city is deforming is moving as a result
of a phenomenon often called underground
climate change
um also term subsurface Urban heat
islands that basically consists of
rising temperatures in the subsurface of
cities the rationale is that soyuz rocks
concrete and materials at large deform
when subjected to temperature variations
and so as a result of these change in
the climatic conditions underground
um soils and rocks the form beneath us
and so also the foundations that rest
upon them the form and what is the heat
Source that's causing this increased
warmth
so we humans produce heat like release
heat when we move when trains in Subway
channels break they release Heat at
least most of the trains uh lightning
system release heat so there are there
are a myriad of heat sources in
underground environments and
um these environments slowly diffuse
heat in their surroundings and so in
solids and rocks and also heat networks
I mean you know a lot of cities have
things like District Heating and pipes
running underground does that have an
effect absolutely yeah see what um see
what's that works uh everything that you
can think of it's really interesting and
you've kind of put all these together
and and Quantified them and they act
they add up do they correct yeah they
add up so you can consider that around
each of these heat sources there is the
formation of uh you could call it a
bubble of heat uh and so the dancer and
the closer together will be these heat
sources the more pronounced uh will
become these bubbles of heat
um and so you can really consider that
there is a change in the climatic
conditions underground the the second
driver is a so-called diffuse driver uh
that consists in the surface component
of uh Urban Hittites which are also
called metrological Urban heat Islands
the idea is that construction materials
typically employ for building envelopes
absorb heat coming from solar radiation
and again anthropogenic activity and the
release that heat at night so that's why
in series are typically warmer than the
surrounding rural areas so the hot
tarmac the hot buildings part of that is
is going down as well and how big is
this kind of deformation this reshaping
of the underground world how damaging
can it be I suppose so
um based on the results of our research
we um we've been able to quantify that
um ground informations can be
particularly complex we can have soil
layers that expand but also contract
upon Heating and these ground
deformations are associated with ground
movements uh and specifically vertical
displacements exceeding 10 millimeters
now the reason why this is significant
is because in civil engineering it's
renowned that vertical displacements of
that order of magnitude can become
problematic for the function of
structures and infrastructures and just
very briefly I know in some cities I
think London is one we've also seen
things like clay drying out and
shrinkage as a result of that so
presumably this it could be compounding
on top of other factors Underground
exactly absolutely yes so um especially
in cities such as London where
there is under an underground climate
change there is a subsurface Urban heat
islands and there are many phenomenon
going on
this is one that is likely to exacerbate
what is already happening
thanks very much Alessandro absolutely
fascinating now from deep below ground
to the green world above the Royal
Botanic Gardens in queue have been
collecting specimens from around the
world for hundreds of years even Charles
Darwin gave them a few they reckon they
got 8 million specimens and they started
to digitize them back in 2021 well
they've now nearly done the first
million and we sent our own Mickey
Carroll down to have a chat with them
this is one of the most biodiverse
places on the planet
for hundreds of years Kew Gardens have
been amassing millions of specimens of
plants and fungi and conserving them to
study
now they're on a mission to modernize
we're trying to digitize all herbivium
specimens held in these buildings the
cupboards you see around you will
contain specimens from all over the
globe we've just imaged our millionth
specimen we've got six million more to
do but we're well on track and we really
want to get this information out we want
to essentially turn this building inside
out so the information we hold can be
used by people worldwide for whichever
environmental issue they're interested
in Dr Sarah Phillips is one of more than
300 people getting this collection
online
so what do you actually mean by
digitizing a plant oh yeah so um what we
mean by that is capturing the
information that you would find on a
herberian specimen and then Imaging it
and producing a high resolution image so
then you can start looking at the
details of the characters and from the
image you know a taxonomist can use it
for their research so here we have a
sample of herbarian specimens
um so they're really sort of plot dried
plant material that have been mounted on
her barium sheets usually kind of glued
on and also as well as the plant itself
you have like label information and that
will be what this what species the plant
is where it's they're from who collected
it and when it was collected and so yeah
here we've got a large selection you
know we've got actually some that we've
been collected from um In Darwin's
collected so these are one from The
Straits of Magellan which is an orchid
so you know we have I think it's around
1834 so we just have a huge variety so
that's a plant that Darwin has yes yeah
yeah he would have like yeah collected
it and been on the Beagle with it around
the around the world and how does
something go from this piece of paper to
something that someone on the other side
of the world can study for their
conservation science
let's have a look at the Imaging station
so the idea behind this is that we take
high resolution images that then a
botanist would be able to zoom in and
have a look at the characters and be
able to check the identification
this gorgeous species is part of the
allium family which became the millionth
specimen to be digitized here at Q
standing in this Garden surrounded by
all the smells and the textures of all
the different flowers it's hard to
imagine that any of this could be turned
into something meaningful that you could
study on the internet but that's exactly
what they're trying to do here they're
trying to take their over 8 million
specimens that they've collected over
the years and just turn them over to the
scientific community
Alan and the team of digitizers are
hopeful their work will improve the
science around plants and climate change
it gives us an idea of which plants are
going to be most threatened and may not
survive quite often the actual species
being used might not survive when it's
currently going but what is it what are
its closest relatives could they be used
are there features in those relatives
which could be brought into food plants
for example which would enable them to
survive in under different climates so
it really provides itself evidence-based
for understanding current use of Parts
but also the future use
from Darwin's hands to the internet in
just a few months Q will open a portal
meaning the whole world has access to
their extraordinary collection
Mickey Carroll Kew Gardens Sky News such
an amazing resource there at Cube quite
unique well that's it for this week
remember you can catch up on all your
climate and environment news on the Sky
News website and app or by scanning the
QR code that is on your screen right now
next week we'll be at the Goodwood
Festival of speed seeing where there's
any chance that synthetic fuels could
make engines climate friendly see you
then
foreign foreign